eccola questa è la prima immagine che mi
è venuta in
e stato proposto di partecipare a the
ideas worth spreading e le idee sono
come letame vanno sparse perché
diventino facciano favoriscano la
crescita e favoriscono l'evoluzione
un'evoluzione che io intendo in termini
darwinisti quella che avviene tramite la
selezione naturale
la selezione naturale che cosa fa
sancisce l'inadeguatezza del giusto
quindi il giusto e ingiusto e l'errore è
giusto cioè l'errore apre nuove
possibilità e nuove possibilità di
salvezza ed è in fondo e progettare vuol
dire in qualche modo proiettare nel
futuro una visione e nel futuro l'unica
cosa che sappiamo è quella quella
certezza socratica del saper di non
sapere ma noi non vi annoierò e vi
parlerò di architettura vi annoierò
parlando di architettura quindi perché
questo è il mio mestiere e quindi
parlando di architettura non possiamo
non parlare e non considerare gli errori
che abbiamo fatto nel territorio per le
ro di architettura quindi dell'errore e
degli errori che abbiamo fatto questa
serie di errori che abbiamo fatto
innumerevoli nel nostro territorio e
abbiamo 22 modi di procedere o pensare
che la politica non ha gestito a
lamentarci perché la politica non ha
gestito bene questo sviluppo e pensare
di restituire alle generazioni future un
paesaggio meraviglioso e
incontaminato cosa che comunque non è
possibile perché il processo è
irreversibile oppure possiamo farci
aiutare dall'arte e vedere una luce in
quello che hanno fatto gli artisti cioè
se pensate alle rovine romane piuttosto
che alle vedute di alcune parti di
venezia dei vedutisti
e ci mettiamo nel
diciamo pensiamo di essere gente di
quell'epoca ci rendiamo subito conto che
a quell'epoca queste non erano così
interessanti non avevo neanche tutta
questa fascinazione che poteva avere per
piranesi piuttosto che per canaletto per
il canaletto e la stessa cosa la
possiamo possiamo dire riguardante
parlando della delle nostre vecchie
fabbriche per gli artisti che cosa hanno
fatto ci hanno messo sotto una nuova
luce ci hanno mostrato in modo diverso
questo queste cose che non erano altro
che uno scarto e anche fotografi come
gabriele basilico ci ha mostrato come
adatto aiutato a dare vita a quella che
oggi tutti conosciamo come archeologia
industriale
in realtà sappiamo tutti che abbiamo
sempre utilizzato il nostro patrimonio
edilizio non è una novità utilizzarlo
però quando lo abbiamo utilizzato
soprattutto in italia quando è un valore
economico ed aveva un valore storico
oppure documentale non l'abbiamo mai
recuperato per tutti gli altri casi
perché perché
perché il territorio non in fondo non
avalon pensiamo che territorio la valore
ma se diamo valore al territorio
cominciamo a dare valore a tutte quelle
infrastrutture quei patti parti
interstiziali della del territorio e
anche appunto di infrastrutture o
piuttosto di oggetti lasciati
nelle campagne e quindi riusciamo a
vedere queste come una nuova possibilità
dobbiamo vedere queste come un nuovo
possibilità di nuovo un nuovo valore un
esempio abbastanza eclatante è la high
line judy di new york
che è una recuperata da diller scofidio
più retro che aveva fatto un parco
lineare che connette due parti della
città hanno recuperato quindi una
vecchia infrastruttura facendola
diventare un parco che appunto continua
a connettere parte città in modo diverso
a velocità chiaramente diverso diverse
però possiamo pensare se pensiamo che
possiamo recuperare una vecchia
infrastruttura perché non possiamo
recuperare gli spazi che stanno che che
solo parte anche delle infrastrutture
che utilizziamo oppure possiamo
progettare delle infrastrutture che
abbiano all'interno dei geni che le faq
che le rendono utilizzabile questo è un
ragionamento che abbiamo portato avanti
quando ci hanno invitato nel 2006 a
partecipare la biennale di venezia
entrando in polemica con l'idea di
occupare ancora territorio perché ho
dimenticato di dire che ci hanno
invitato a progettare una parte di una
nuova città nella pianura padana
abbiamo pensato di dire ok lavoriamo su
quello che l'infrastruttura tentiamo di
dare all'infrastruttura un nuovo un
nuovo significato e quindi abbiamo
tentato di creare degli spazi
appartenenti anche l'infrastruttura che
potessero essere utilizzati ad un
diverso livello ed è ed abbiamo
progettato una scuola che stessa
all'interno dell'infrastruttura appunto
e poi inserendo un gene rigenerativo
cioè in modo che questa infrastruttura
una volta non più utilizzato diventasse
il nuovo territorio nuovo territorio per
la litania di villette che piace tanto
alla speculazione edilizia tanto che si
chiamava il progetto le vie della
speculazione sono infinite e la
unità veloci perché passa il tempo e
quindi
abbiamo comunque capito due cose da
quella che l'architetto deve progettare
nelle case chiaramente però deve
progettare anche dei territori e oltre a
enna è un'altra cosa molto e deve anzi
pre sarà il territorio ai territori
nuovi ed un'altra cosa molto importante
è che stiamo creando due mondi
completamente diversi il mondo della del
monumento il mondo da vedere il mondo da
vivere e quando questi entrano in
collisione si crea un disastro ed è e
chi ci rimette generalmente è il mondo
da vedere quindi il monumento è un
esempio abbastanza chiara sono le ville
venete se pensate il veneto nel veneto
queste ville creavano erano l'elemento
organizzatore del territorio veneto e
friuli ci sono circa 5 mila di queste
strutture per all organizzavano
economicamente dal punto di vista
urbanistico e dal punto di vista
produttivo perché c'erano le barchesse
di produzione in realtà oggi tutti
questi ruoli ne ha già persi ed è
rimasto solo un monumento e se vedete
questa immagine vi sembra mi sembra
abbastanza evidente come il suo ruolo
unico si è rimasto il suo scatolone
bello vuoto da da da guardare e non ha
più importanza del territorio però c'è
una figlia illegittima della della villa
veneta che è la villetta veneta la
villetta veneta che ha anche le anche
lei è costruita per essere di
rappresentanza c'è la piccola casetta
con la sua barchessa tra virgolette
illegittima anche quella che è il
capanno il capannone di per la
produzione allora questa è la cellula
base del benessere del nord est su
questa questa cellula base ha invaso
completamente il territorio prima della
normative urbanistiche ed oggi noi
possiamo dobbiamo
dobbiamo pensare che cosa farne abbiamo
avuto l'opportunità di riflettere su
questo quando ci è stato affidato questo
il progetto ed abbiamo avuto la fortuna
che era il progetto di una ruck e che
operava nel recupero dei rottami quindi
recupero la già un gene all'interno del
progetto è la cosa importante ci sono
subito venuti in mente gli artisti da
deschamps per piuttosto a quelli del
nouveau réalisme francese tipo césar
chiaramente e quindi che cosa come
operavano questi artisti nello stesso
modo come operava pira tramite
l'astrazione guardava metteva sotto
mettevano sotto una luce diversa oggetti
che erano oggetti che non avevano nessun
valore quindi lo spiazzamento
dell'oggetto il dargli una funzione
diversa gli dava contemporaneamente un
valore diverso ed è questo il modo come
abbiamo operato abbiamo selezionato
degli oggetti li abbiamo spia spiazzate
li abbiamo dati dei ruoli diversi data
un'importanza diversa e l'abbiamo creato
un paesaggio diverso è lo stesso la
stessa villetta è diventata uno ce
trouvé da piazzare in uno scenario nuovo
quindi di nuovo l'architetto che provava
a creare un territorio e l'architetto
che in qualche modo opera anche come un
chirurgo cioè colui che va non come il
demiurgo come ci hanno insegnato ma come
chirurgo colui che va a togliere quello
che e in più e ad aggiungere solo lo
stretto necessario preparare di
architettura in termini sperimentali
dobbiamo renderci conto che è molto
difficile fare sperimentazione con
l'architettura perché la cultura costa
un costo sociale ha un costo economico
ha un costo ecologico e gli errori anno
non possono essere eliminati facilmente
quindi dobbiamo andare a studiare gli
errori che sono stati fatti o gli errori
che si fanno in mentre si si opera
mentre si fa architettura la parte
progettuale ma anche nella parte
costruttiva e questo è il caso di questo
progetto che noi abbiamo fatto a chi era
in una zona degradata che nella prima
cintura torinese e in questa zona
degradata abbiamo inserito abbiamo
voluto inserire un virus in qualche modo
che rigenerasse l'area l'area urbana
tutta quest'area urbana questo virus
doveva doveva in realtà
trasformare l'area sia dal punto di
vista economico che dal punto di vista
sociale
l'idea che avevamo avuto niente di
originale era quella di creare una
grande vetrata che diventasse
trasparente che facesse vedere l'interno
e l'esterno e il lusso che si che veniva
realizzato era percepibile anche
dall'esterno e quindi questa era sembra
ci sembrava una gran figata in realtà
questa questa questo difficile abbiamo
rivolto a nord ovest ed era sbagli ed è
stato un grandissimo errore tanto che la
l'edificio quando dai calcoli del termo
tecnico si riscaldi surriscaldava in un
modo incredibile e quindi sarebbe
costato tantissimo tenerlo fresco su
questo errore ci abbiamo abbiamo
lavorato e stata una grandissima
opportunità perché l'abbiamo fatto
diventare una fontana abbiamo
raffrescato tutta la facciata con
dell'acqua e questo aiuto un duplice
effetto
il primo effetto è stato carattere stato
effettivamente all'interno secondo
effetto che raffrescato l'esterno e con
il rumore ha creato uno spazio urbano
quindi quello che ci proponevamo che non
avremmo sicuramente raggiunto con la
prima idea è invece successo proprio
grazie a questo errore
inoltre c'era stato un problema che
l'acqua ha cominciato a bagnare le
signore che si lamentavano per la strada
allora abbiamo detto allora abbiamo
aggiunto un altro layer a questo a
questo è difficile quindi la facciata
diventata una facciata tridimensionale
che pare essere la cosa sia piaciuta di
più e facendo questo e facendo questo
abbiamo creato quel velo di distanza tra
interno ed esterno che non separa ma
comunque crea crea uno spazio ovattato
all'interno in qualche modo abbiamo
fatto un edificio che è una somma di
errori e ci consoliamo pensando che gli
errori hanno prodotto delle cose molto
molto buone e molto interessanti e gli
errori sugli errori hanno prodotto cose
ancora ancora più interessante fa solo
un dubbio che mi è sorto in durante
questi questa giornata e il per il ruolo
della tecnologia e il ruolo della
tecnologia spero ci aiuti a migliorare
la nostra vita ma non a non fare errori
perché se non ci fanno fare gli errori
ci troveremmo non sa non potremo più
evolverci e probabilmente si ridurrà
molto quel triangolo che vede in roma
come la capitale del medio sud grazie
migliori